[Music]
hey there more garrett here bringing you
another ghoulish episode of rt
essentials where today we'll be breaking
down the most iconic horror movie
villains of all time
[Music]
i got the creeps but we've also rounded
out a veritable rogue gallery of ghouls
goblins and yolk dudes in masks who just
refuse to go down no matter how many
times you shoot drown or decapitate them
i know i've tried that spoiler alert is
on seat belts fastened popcorn ready and
adult diapers on check check
and check
it's time for rt essentials iconic
horror movie baddies
chucky
child's play franchise nothing like a
strangulation to get the circulation
going to get jurassic park the real
animatronic magic show was in 1988's
child's play the plot is pretty
straightforward just a normal serial
killer possessing the body of a doll and
befriending his young owner in an
attempt to possess the kid's human form
making sure to murder a bunch of people
along the way and the face of this
doll creator don mancini's father worked
in advertising which is what gave him
the idea for a killer marketed as a
literal good guy doll originally the
movie was supposed to be a dark satire
about the dangers of shilling cursed
merchandise to children before rewrites
turned it into a more straightforward
horror i'm not ashamed to be a killer
it's not an addiction it is a choice
brad durev voiced chucky through seven
films before being replaced by mark
hamill for the 2019 reboot maybe i need
to open you up and see what we're
dealing with
i'm gonna fix you andy
despite being such a pivotal part of the
character duraff rarely appeared on set
with the doll he recorded the lines in
advance so the animatronic team could
match up the doll's mouth duraff would
also act out the scenes in person with
the actors for their reaction shots
there was more than one chucky doll as
the animatronics team could only make a
doll do one specific action so there was
a flailing chucky a walking chucky and a
standing still chucky
chucky was based in part on the popular
talking corky doll surprising no one who
owned a corky doll up until the day that
they saw this movie and then it went
straight in the trash go ahead and shoot
i'll be back i always come back
[Music]
yay
but dying is such a
freddy krueger a nightmare on elm street
franchise please god this
is god
where's craven really broke or slashed
the mold when he made freddy krueger the
king at dream ghoul in 1984's nightmare
on elm street unlike his strong silent
slasher contemporaries jason voorhees
and michael myers freddy krueger existed
firmly in the realm of the supernatural
a janitor fred kruger was cornered and
set on fire by the parents of springwood
after it was discovered he'd been
preying on their children and years
later starts popping up in their
teenager's dreams wearing a long razor
glove and killing them with increasingly
elaborate fantasy sequences
freddy also differed from the strong
sulking stalkers in another way he was
super chatty and in his human form
rather scrawny it's hard to imagine
anyone other than robert england
gleefully announcing some of the
franchise's signature lines now i'm
playing with power
but craven originally wanted a bigger
hulking krueger british actor david
warner known for his role in titanic and
star trek was originally cast but had to
drop out due to scheduling conflicts
england took the part gleefully and thus
freddy krueger was born what's with kids
today huh no
respect originally freddie wasn't quite
the jokester that he'd later evolve into
in fact craven imagined him more like
amayas or vorhees with only 10 minutes
of total screen time in the original
film freddy doesn't have a whole lot to
say but in subsequent films he would
practically perfect a tight 15 minute
set during his kills
[Music]
most famous of which was in nightmare on
elm street part 3 the dream warriors
where he appears with zaza gabor on a
talk show before becoming the tv with
extended arms and shoving a girl
headfirst into the screen while quipping
welcome to prime time
this is it jennifer your big
craven got the idea for a killer dream
after reading a story of three men who
escaped pol pot's tyrannical rule only
to suffer from nightmares so bad they
stopped sleeping when the men did pass
out from exhaustion all three suffered
the same scary fate a nightmare so bad
they would wake up screaming before
immediately dropping dead autopsies
revealed the men's hearts hadn't given
out they seemingly were just scared to
death i'll give you my pretty and your
little soul too
jigsaw sore franchise where is he where
is he that's a problem you're gonna have
to solve before it's too late
it has about two hours before the gas
creeping into his nervous system begins
to break down his body tissue and he
begins to bleed from every orifice he
has
oh yes
there will be blood
though most fans of the soar franchise
remember the name john kramer the
marionette he used in introduction
videos for victims to play a little game
is named billy the puppet hello amanda
you don't know me but
i know you
i want to play a game billy can be found
in one form or another across all of
director james wan's films but as creepy
as billy was he was actually an homage
to a horror maestro daario argento's
deep red also features a creepy doll as
well as the signature black gloves worn
by the killer in saw but while deep red
featured more of a talking tina doll
with a knife billy was more of a
tricycle riding dandy
it's the bow tie so dabble
what do you say look
what do you say tell me what you want
i want to know if you have what it takes
to survive writer and star lee winnell
came up with the concept of jigsaw a
killer with a benevolent streak who only
wants you to appreciate life in a
neurology ward plagued by headaches
winnell wondered what he'd do if he only
had a few years to live of course the
idea for soar came from a bad headache
there are actually so many fun facts
about jigsaw that it's hard to just pick
one but we'll leave you with this no
dummy was used for the body actor tobin
bell actually laid face down in the
middle of the room for the entirety of
the 18-day shoot talk about commitment
or just finding a smart way to get paid
while taking a nap on set
jigs
i just knew i needed a second
candyman the candyman franchise death
would be a tale to frighten children
come with me
and be immortal candyman is an iconic
piece of black horror canon but the
source material actually pegged the
titular beholding antagonist as a white
man
in adapting clive barker's short story
the forbidden director bernard rose
transplanted the action to inner city
chicago turning its main character into
a black man who's been the victim of a
lynch mob the mythos of candyman was
based on a real-life incident where a
chicago woman was found murdered in her
apartment after complaining that men had
been entering her home through her
mirror the police found the intruders
had indeed come from the abandoned
apartment next door climbing in through
the bathroom vanity that building down
the street from the one where they shot
the majority of candyman
candyman's sweet tooth came with a buggy
issue rose wanted real bees on set
candyman actor tony todd worked it into
his contract that he would get a one
thousand dollar bonus any time he was
stung by a big he left the series with
an extra twenty three thousand dollars
for
filming in the original location of
cabrini green neighborhood despite the
high rises having been demolished and
while the urban horror movie was
considered pretty boundary pushing at
the time the new movie incorporates the
politics of the black lives matter
movement and ties candyman's fate to it
you want to be a part of the story right
no
say
his name
candy man
norman bates psycho franchise she needs
me
it's not as if she were
a maniac
a raving thing
she just goes
a little mad sometimes
we all go a little mad sometimes
norman bates the ultimate mama's boy
terrified audiences when he appeared in
alfred hitchcock's 1960 classic psycho
portraying the creepy young hotel owner
actor anthony perkins appeared as norman
in the subsequent three sequels and is
probably the most well known of the
normans but the character has been
played by actors like kurt paul in the
1987 made for tv movie bates motel
freddie highmore in bates motel the amc
series vince vaughn in the gus van sant
1998 remake and perkins's own son oz
perkins in psycho 2. one of perkins
final appearances as norman was actually
in a bizarre oatmeal crisp commercial in
1990. freddie highmore's portrayal of
norman bates brought new life and blood
to the old bogeyman telling the story of
young norman growing up with his mother
norma in a town that resembled an even
creepier twin peaks please try not to
worry okay
i'll take good care of you i promise
actress vera famiga encouraged the show
to hire freddie whom she'd seen in the
art of getting by even promising
producers should sign on for the show if
they hired him that sure is some high
praise for the young actor and i tell
you what their chemistry on screen
really was genuine
serial killer ed gein known as the
plainfield ghoul was the basis for
norman bates as he presented as a very
average man whose distinguishing trait
was a very close relationship with his
mother guys would also serve as the
inspiration for leatherface buffalo bill
from silence of the lambs and countless
other scary baddies
wouldn't even have a fly
[Music]
leatherface the texas chainsaw massacre
franchise
since 1974 audiences have been terrified
of going on road trips through rural
places thanks to the chainsaw wielding
human skin mask wearing psychopath
leatherface portrayed in toby hooper's
the texas chainsaw massacre
[Music]
but despite the horror the character
invokes he's never been the main villain
of the franchise that would be his
redneck family the sawyers whom
leatherface is always working on their
behalf in fact by the time we get to
texas chainsaw massacre 3d in 2013 he's
actually the misunderstood anti-hero
it's me
you know what they say die a villain or
live long enough to save the girl
yelling do you think cuz
do you think
according to hooper one of his
inspirations for leatherface came from a
particularly gory story told to him by a
doctor friend of his who is a pre-med
student had gone and skinned the face of
a cadaver and worn it out for halloween
that's sick hoopa decided leatherface
should have different skin masks to fit
each of his moods and he's a very moody
boy hooper had one very effective trick
for getting the most out of his cast of
relatively obscure local actors none of
them ever saw stuntman gunner hansen in
full leatherface until it was time for
their death scene
and they had a good reason to be scared
they used real chainsaws with actual
chains
that led to some close calls with the
actors with the mask on gunner had no
peripheral vision and during one take he
tripped and fell the revved up chainsaw
flew in the air landing inches from his
face
thankfully leatherface got to keep his
mug
pinhead hellraiser franchise he's got
pins in his head what you think of his
pain
it's only a shadow
pain
has a face
i
am
pain
clive barker scared audiences out of
their seats with his 1987 horror classic
hellraiser which featured a demonic
puzzle box a race of multi-dimensional
pain-loving beings called cenobites and
of course their iconic leader
pinhead funnily enough in the original
movie however the character played by
doug bradley was just referred to as
lead cenobyte in the original script
pinhead it was just a fan name that
happened to stick as it were in later
sequels that's how the movies referred
to him when people say you look like a
million bucks they're usually not
talking about the star villain of
hellraiser but that was in fact the
entire budget given to first-time
director barca to make hellraiser which
ended up exponentially earning it back
with a 20 million box office smash and
if anyone was confused about where that
time and money went it took six hours
for bradley to transform into the
needle-nosed pinhead and by the later
films he became so adept at it that he
was credited as assistant makeup artist
unlike the other big baddies at the time
the rogue's gallery of krugers mayas and
voorhees barker envisioned pinhead not
as some silent lumbering shape nor some
wisecracking fiend instead reading the
script bradley saw him as a cross
between noel coward and oscar wilde
barker has confirmed pinhead as an
articulate intelligent high priest from
hell
saying during an interview i don't find
dumb things terribly scary
alright but clive counterpoint
zombies
they're pretty scary
oh yes joseph
oh yes
you have forsaken yourself and while
hellraiser may have put pinhead on the
map it wasn't the first appearance of
the character would you believe me if i
told you pinhead first showed up in a
musical when barker adapted hunters in
the snow for the stage he cast bradley
as an undead conquistador and torturer
later his short film the forbidden
featured a block of wood with six nails
sticking out shot from different creepy
angles to distort the light combine
bradley's performance with that block of
wood and you get one of the most
visually revolting horror monsters of
all time now let's put a pin in this
and move on to our next master of horror
i
am the way
hannibal lecter hannibal franchise
a census taker once tried to test me
i ate his liver with some fava beans and
a nice chianti
you know we love to give freddy credit
for all the good puns but there's at
least one scary fella that would
consider that a bit
rude we are talking of course about dr
hannibal lecter renowned forensic
psychiatrist and toast of baltimore's
high society who ends silence of the
lambs by telling agent clarice starling
he's having an old friend for dinner
that is one self-aware cannibal we're
glad he kept a sense of humor that one i
do wish we could chat longer but
i'm having an old friend for dinner
lecture is one of the few horror
villains that transcends the serial
killer in a horror movie archetype
anthony hopkins won an oscar for playing
him in silence of the lambs while actor
mads mikkelsen won a saturn award for
his interpretation of the role in nbc's
hannibal traditionally made with pig's
blood in this case a local cow
and when you last made it for me
the blood was from a cow only in the
derogatory sense lecter was named the
greatest villain in american history by
the american film institute in 2003
beating such heavy hitters as norman
bates darth vader and the wicked witch
of the west we may associate hannibal
with sir anthony or mads but it was
actually brian cox who first played the
good doctor in 1986's man hunter you're
your hands are rough
they don't look like cop's hands anymore
and that shaving lotion is something a
child would select it has a ship on the
bottle doesn't
don't think you can persuade me with
appeals to my intellectual vanity
originally director michael mann had
wanted to cast william friedkin yeah the
director of the exorcist to play lecter
before seeing cox perform on stage
meanwhile we can thank david lynch for
the most iconic portrayal of lecter in
cinema silence of the lambs director
jonathan demi was inspired to cast sir
hopkins after seeing him in lynch's 1980
elephant man i've been in this room for
eight years now clerics
i know they will never ever let me out
while i'm alive
what i want is a view
i want a window where i can see a tree
or even water hannibal lecter is a
unique kind of killer he's an overly
polite erudite sociopathic cannibal who
thinks he's smarter than everyone else
so when he finds people he likes he
tends to bond pretty hard
above
or below the wrist
what people don't know is how author
thomas harris originally had this play
out at the end of the novel hannibal dr
lecter is spotted by a former guard at
an argentinian opera where he's
accompanied by his wife clarice styling
yeah mic drop harris ends the novel
telling us that starling and hannibal
ran off got married and lived happily
ever after in a giant mansion where they
danced learned new languages and as the
novel specifically points out do not
take psychoactive drugs and consume the
face of their servants ah true love i'm
happy for them i also much prefer the
movies ending
ghost face scream franchise
there are few horror villains in the
last two decades with masks as iconic as
those worn by the various ghostface
killers across the screen franchise the
story behind the spooky face garb is
pretty neat while scouting locations for
the original wes craven film a producer
went on location to the house featured
in alfred hitchcock's shadow of a doubt
inside the home a ghost-faced mask was
hanging on a post when she took the
photos of the home back to work craven
loved the look so much that he decided
to use it for the movie's killers
but it doesn't end there see craven
didn't own the rides that particular
costume so it was altered slightly to
avoid copyright infringement however
after the movie was a hit the original
manufacturers fun world struck a deal
with dimension films to rebrand the
model as the ghost faced mask you'd
think with such drama over getting the
rights to signature ghostface accessory
the franchise would make it front and
center of their marketing campaign and
not so ghostface did not appear on any
of the official posters for the american
marketing until the fourth film
though scream has had many killers over
the course of the saga at least two per
movie meaning eight in total not
including the new film there's a lot of
bad people audiences are supposed to
recognize ghostface as the same entity
from the prior films the mask helps but
the other half of the equation is actor
roger jackson who provided ghostface's
phone voice in every film
remember
hello
what do you want
i want you
it's show time
to keep an air of mystery during the
original screen production jackson was
actually on the other end of the phone
calls during the shoot taunting his
victims but craven kept him purposely
hidden in another room so until
production wrapped no one in the cast
had laid eyes on the guy asking them
about their favorite scary movie which
is all cool and all but man maybe just
trust your actors to
you know be able to act scared instead
of creating elaborate schemes for
freaking them out to get a reaction huh
[Music]
annabelle the conjuring universe
[Music]
[Music]
the conjuring franchise has
approximately a million spin-offs at
this point but none so recognizable as
annabelle the creepy demonic doll kept
in the warren secure facility aka in
their home but while you think you might
know annabelle if you picked her up at a
thrift store think again the real-life
version of annabelle was a plain old
raggedy ann doll and yes it can still be
viewed by visiting the warren's occult
museum today which again is just their
basement people
look i'm no demonologist but maybe
moving her isn't the best idea on the
other hand what could possibly go wrong
oh right the inexplicable accidents that
happened in or around the set of various
film sets in the conjuring verse like
star view of mega finding claw marks all
over her home and body we wouldn't call
it a cursed production but the studio
might during the filming of annabelle
comes home a priest was brought in to
bless the set he even gave the young
star mckenna grace a rosary blessed by
pope francis
it worked as the power of christ
compelled her to bow out of the
franchise after the one film
much like billy the puppet annabelle is
part of the larger extended universe
crossing over in not just one but two dc
eu films look close and you can spot her
in cameos during aquaman and shazam the
two dceu films directed by conjuring
versus james 1 and david f sandberg the
real question is can demons count as
easter eggs if they don't recognize
easter and speaking of crossovers
child's play creator don mancini has
stated he would like to someday make a
chucky annabelle crossover film
yay
michael myers halloween franchise
michael myers groovy baby no not that
one the killer in halloween maybe a
household name today but he didn't start
out as one in john carpenter's original
1978 version his name is only spoken
once at the beginning of the film
michael
no one says it outright for the rest of
the movie and he's credited as the shape
the shape honestly sounds like a great
name for an indie wrestler which makes
sense given how much mayas and the
halloween franchise have given and taken
from the world of wrestling mgm grand
champion tyler main portrayed the
tallest variant of michael myers who
stood a wobbling six foot eight in rob
zombie's 2007 remake meanwhile wwe
legend the undertaker got his signature
move from myers who in the first film
goes from lying prone on the floor to
sitting up ram rod straight in one
cripply fluid motion
michael was not revealed to be laurie
strode's brother until the second film
carpenter and curtis ended up deeply
regretting this revelation as they felt
it cheapened michael's intimidation of
being a total unknown stranger this
would be retconned back in the 2018 film
oh and just in case you were absent the
day that they went over this in high
school movie trivia class michael myers
white rubber mask which he steals from a
hardware store is actually william
shatner's face from his role in star
trek yeah they just elongated the eyes
and voila from kirk to creep a perfect
midday makeover
trick or treat
jason voorhees friday the 13th franchise
for all the credit we give jason
voorhees it's easy to forget how friday
the 13th didn't begin with him as the
bad guy it's debatable if he's even in
the original 1980 film where it's
revealed that mrs voorhees jason's
mother has been behind all the creative
camp killings seeking vengeance for her
son who drowned while counsellors were
busy getting busy
that's better
[Music]
even more outrageous it's a fun fact
about jason's famous hockey mask he
doesn't even wear it until the end of
friday the 13th part 3. yeah the second
movie he's wearing just a straight-up
burlap sack over his face somehow just
not as effective producers originally
wanted jason to wear an umpire mask but
decided a hockey mask would cover more
of his face and reduce the need for
prosthetics as it was already canon that
jason has a huge weird-looking noggin
[Music]
and that's a delicate way to say it and
if you're really looking to stir the pot
at the next horror convention just bring
up the fact that jason voorhees
technically holds the record for highest
kill count of any slasher racking up 150
on-screen deaths over the course of the
franchise and that's not even including
the entire space colony's worth of
people that he just exploded in jason x
watch as everyone loses their collective
minds debating whether or not half of
those freddie versus jason kills can
even be attributed by voorhees if he was
actually being controlled by ghost
krueger
[Music]
and we'll leave you with one last nugget
about jason his infamous music cue you
know the
yeah that was created by sampling betsy
palmer's line in the original whereas
mrs voorhees she begins to channel jason
chanting kill them mummy kill her mommy
now you'll never be able to unhear that
or unsee the fact that i went
so that's our list folks of the scariest
movie villains in horror history of
course we didn't have room for everybody
on here sorry wolfman and sincerest
apologies to bella lagossi so please go
on rottentomatoes.com and drop a comment
telling us who you think belongs on the
list of s-level slayers thanks for
tuning in folks and until next time
remember if you're pairing fava beans
with anything it's gotta be
[Music]
[Music]